you testified in the Johnny Depp Amber
Heard trial based on your role as a
clinical and forensic psychologist it
was watched by I don't know how many
people maybe tens maybe hundreds of
millions of people what was that
experience like thank God I didn't know
that at the time
um were you scared
oh yeah given the size of the platform
how many people are watching and not
scared typically isn't the word when I
testify I'm always
um
excited and a little trepidatious before
I testify because the stakes are so high
for everybody's life in that room
um this was different I I anxiety isn't
usually my brand
um and I just skipped anxiety that
Maureen went straight to Terror and it
was mad I was mad at the legal it was
funny like I was having all these strong
emotions I couldn't find my bobby pins I
almost started crying because I couldn't
find them uh I was pretty unhinged that
morning and in a way that was really
unfamiliar to me and it was right when I
cried because I couldn't find my bobby
pins that I realized I needed to get a
grip and that I was a professional and
that my hair didn't matter even though
it ended up mattering people noticed
that it was crazy
um but I got a grip and I went in and I
just did my job
so the terror in the end helped you
focus and do your job well I think it
does and it's a little scary though
because I know what fear does
cognitively and there is a sweet spot
where you want some stress and then you
can be really acutely focused and
attuned but then if you go over this
threshold you get sort of that frontal
lobe shutdown where you're not thinking
clearly and everybody knows that
experience from taking a really
stressful test at some point like in
high school and then they're going over
the answers with the teacher in class
later and they're like how did I miss
that question I know that they you're
just in a different state that's when
you have too much stress I think this
day I actually was bordering on too much
stress if not clearly in that threshold
but um
once you're sitting there for a little
bit and you're asked the questions you
can kind of go into a routine of just
wanting to talk about your work
so what is the work the job of a
forensic psychologist in that context
in the deaf herd trial I was
um
serving as an expert witness based on a
psychological evaluation of one of the
parties so forensic psychologists can
serve the court or in legal matters in a
number of ways they can act as a
confidential consultant for an attorney
on a case
or they can even assist with jury
selection they might testify without
doing an evaluation if they're just
coming to testify about sort of a
subject matter
and then they wouldn't be answering
specific questions to either the parties
but just talking more hypothetically
about an a field area in this case
because I was ordered to conduct an
evaluation
I evaluated one of the parties and then
you provide a report to the court with
your findings and then you testify as to
what your findings were but from my
perspective just watching you seem to
have held it together really well so
what do you attribute that to so you
said like it calmed down after you were
able to ask the question so to me if I
were just to put myself in your place
it seems like the internet and the world
would be very nitpicky about individual
words you're speaking from a place
of um a scientific rigor so you have to
be very precise with the awarding
precise I would feel like so much
pressure about each single word I choose
did you feel that pressure that you had
to be extremely precise with the words
always the pressure is so high going in
to testifying I think that's where I
feel the most pressure is preparing and
literally the moment until I start
having to answer and then I don't even
have the luxury of thinking about myself
because it is so important that that
answer be
clarified and understandable to the
court that that becomes my focus and
that's the godsend is that I can stop
thinking about how scary it all is
because I need to pay attention to
explaining something
so I if it's okay I would love to talk
to you about the the personality
assessment test because I think it's
actually super fascinating uh but
personality assessment inventory or the
mmpi too you're probably referring to
the mmpi too which is one I talked a lot
about mmpi too yeah so maybe can you
explain the mmpi to seems fascinating it
is it has like its output the results
has some basic skills as code types and
just reading through the different
complex it's the thing of beauty because
the human mind is really complicated
even you know depression schizophrenia
uh bipolar disorder like all of these
things are really complicated there's
like we many of them we don't understand
well this seems to be a huge amount of
variance and yet you have to be able to
stitch together a bunch of
characteristics that give you intuition
about
the unique aspects of each person you
want to be able to have tests that get
you closer to identifying The Peculiar
flaws or uh beauties of a particular
mind so this seems to do a good job just
reading through the different
descriptions of the code testify that
was the best description I don't know I
mean poetic I apologize beautiful
description you have to be in part
poetic about the human mind it's not
it's not math it's it's psychology okay
so what is the mmpi to like what what
what are we talking about here like uh
it's a questionnaire
yes that's a great start so it it is a
questionnaire uh yet 567 yes no
questions
I'm going to tell you what's most
beautiful about this test so they used
an empirical keying method to develop it
what that means is that they didn't have
a bunch of psychologists get together
and say let's ask them
um let's make sure that we identify
people who have somatic complaints or
physical complaints by asking them
questions about like numbness in their
hands nothing like that what they did
instead was they threw you know like
take a thousand questions at a group of
people who they know at a certain mental
illness and a group of people who didn't
have that mental illness and then they
looked for patterns in what the people
with the mental illness
endorsed as yes and no of those random
questions so it would be for instance
there's a bronze light fixture right
there one of the questions out of the
Thousand might be I like light fixtures
that are bronze true or false and they
looked for correlations in the way
people would answer to these completely
innocuous just boring questions so there
was no real way that a test taker could
foresee the point of answering
and so because they can't foresee it's
very difficult to cheat to get to a
conclusion very difficult and not only
that but you can imagine using that
approach you can then look for patterns
for almost any type of
response style for any type of
Personality trait any type of mental
illness you just get a comparison group
and then a group who's using that
specific strategy or has that specific
mental illness or has that personality
trait
um and you just look for patterns
and there's a scale output of different
kinds
so types yep so we've got you've got
validity scales and those are just
fascinating and often one of the most
useful parts of this test in forensic
contexts because they show you how a
person is approaching the test how
they're answering questions about
themselves so for instance you can see
if they are tired you can see if they're
kind of responding randomly you can see
if they are in an unsophisticated manner
trying to make themselves look perfect
but not very nuanced you can see if they
may be deceiving themselves and truly
believe that they are perfect whereas
others don't see it that way you can see
if they're exaggerating you can see if
they're exaggerating because they're
truly
um it's a cry for help they are in
extreme distress but they feel as though
they need to really punctuate it to get
people to notice or you can see if
they're exaggerating in a way that is
um you know driven for a specific
outcome or gain it's just fascinating
and it's the most well-developed
assessment we have for a person's
approach to
answering questions about themselves so
it gives you the context of how honest
they're being the state of the person is
their answer to them yeah yeah their
honesty their how forthcoming they're
being and how accurate they're being and
then the the result of the
classification based on the test is are
these code types right well so you have
these clinical skills as well you have
10 clinical skills that look for
different
um kind of primary Clinical Pathology
issues
this test doesn't tell you anything good
about yourself at best it just tells you
that you're not responding in a way that
is uh dishonest and that you are uh kind
not hugely problematic but there's you
know it's not looking for strength so
you have these 10 clinical scales that
look for variations above the mean of
the population
um in certain areas anywhere from you
know depressive symptoms manic symptoms
physical complaints anxiety nervousness
aggression social engagement whole scope
of human experience and then there are
much more nuanced scales from those so
little sub scales and then the real
power though of the mmpi2 is in as you
said these code types and these code
types are additional patterns that have
been detected that really can be more
defining of a personality so you look
for Peaks there can be either two
extreme Peaks or three typically that
make a code type and those Peaks are
higher scores on these personality
traits and specific code types can give
you a very nuanced picture of a person's
General approach to life and their
personal relationships just their
personality so you can build on top of
those code types and understanding yeah
how that person is going to deal with
different kinds of situations and then
there's by the way a lot of code types
there are a lot of questions pretty
interesting it is true
I was I wanted to see which one I would
I have given it to some people in my
life it's just phenomenal how hard is it
on your side of the table to give the
test oh it's easy you just Proctor you
just make sure that somebody there's no
distraction that they're well rested
they are sitting there and they can just
take it in front of you so I guess the
question is because the questions are
well designed in that it's hard to mess
with them you just give the it's very
hard to beat it you just hand it to them
and it's yes and no it's yes and no
okay but I should also add to this that
this test as much as I love it and it is
the most researched and widely used
personality assessment in the world
um
it is not in and of itself definitive so
you use it like you already have sort of
a hypothesis and you use this for
clarification okay
um and it has a ton of value for showing
somebody's response or their approach
um how forthcoming they're being but
other than that you really need to
consider it as a piece of the puzzle you
had said stitched together earlier and
that was just one of those points you
made that was perfect for describing
this
there's probably no one perfect test
right for personality no
I wonder especially with advancements of
um AI
there could be more
more and more sophisticated ways of
measuring of collecting data about your
behavior absolutely there could be and
being able to measure some kind of more
productive kind of
especially not in forensic context but
more in uh trying to figure out like how
to improve your lifestyle improve your
relationships all that kind of stuff so
the the results of the test with um
with Amber Heard if you can speak to the
public stuff
he said that the results of misheard's
evaluation supported two diagnoses
borderline personality disorder and
hysterionic personality disorder
can you speak to each one of those what
are they what are the basic
characteristics of borderline
personality disorder sure well so right
now are the DSM-5 which is sort of the
Bible for mental disorders it's what we
go to our diagnostic manual it
classifies personality disorders
according to clusters
and cluster B is one that involves the
emotionally erratic interpersonally
erratic emotional disorders and those
include histrionic personality disorder
borderline personality disorder
narcissistic personality disorder and
anti-social personality disorder
eventually there's been some research on
this and a lot of support for us
eventually moving into a more Spectrum
type approach to considering personality
disorders where you'd essentially be
looking at dysfunction in different
domains of somebody's functioning that
has persisted over time and again the
really important part is this it seems
to be a stable trait part of their
personality that person you know it's in
their interpersonal relationships it's
in how they handle their own life their
own functioning their mood and it's not
just situation based it seems to be all
areas
um I don't love
the title histrionic personality
disorder I think its history is um
it's pretty controversial and there's
some misogyny in it but that all being
said as a servant to the court and
somebody who is there to just provide
the science as it exists today
my job is to relay and in this specific
case I was ordered to provide my
diagnostic Impressions
um a diagnosis and I don't get to decide
which diagnosis uh whether I like a
certain diagnosis or not ultimately if
the criteria are met that diagnosis is
given so as we have it right now with
the current personality disorder
categories histrionic personality
disorder is probably the most
controversial some people believe that
it is narcissistic personality disorder
light so sort of a less obvious less
malicious version of narcissistic
personality disorder
and I think that will probably get
sussed out if we do move to a more
Spectrum based approach because then you
would be describing sort of a
personality disorder and then you would
add the traits to it so you know with
issues and interpersonal functioning and
and Etc so you could be a little bit
more
specific rather than have to just put
somebody in a category so that's where
things are moving you're saying that's
where things are moving from a cluster's
based view of NPD anti-social
personality disorder to more of a
spectrum with personality dysfunction
then you you list the traits that are
there and I think that'll be more
accurate um especially there's so much
overlap between these personality
disorders right now especially cluster B
it is not uncommon for people to have
two or three personality disorders to
meet criteria for two or three at the
same time so speaking about borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder
um borderline personality disorder can
best be thought of as a disorder of
instability and impulsiveness emotional
instability instability in a person's
self-identity sense of self instability
in a person's relationships and then
underlying all of this is an intense
fear of Abandonment histrionic
personality just order
is more of a disorder of emotionality
Dramatics and attention seeking
this you know histrionic disorder
typically is known for The Dramatics and
people who are observing or interacting
with somebody with this disorder may
even feel themselves almost kind of
wanting to turn away there's a sense of
play acting as the person is speaking or
engaging with you
um
something just feels a little bit
disingenuous
and a lot of attention seeking similar
to borderline personality disorder you
might see with histrionic personality
disorder attempts to manipulate however
the motivation with histrionic
personality disorder is that attention
whereas with borderline personality
disorder the underlying motivation for
almost everything is to avoid
abandonment so you'll see frantic
attempts to avoid abandonment frantic
attempts to keep people close and those
frantic attempts can be really harmful
to the person and to others
to the person themselves
so the fear of Abandonment can
result in the very thing you're afraid
of right
and and I there has been some research
also to suggest that there that
borderline personality disorder has
different types as well
um
and I think this is really important
because in my own work I have
encountered many people with borderline
personality disorder in my own life
right
um
and there are different types right I
I'm thinking specifically of a girl I
really love who I've worked with for
years who is so self-aware about this
and endearing and uh she she owns her
I can forgive almost anything if
somebody just owns their
um she is she might lose her temper she
might
um lash out she can be erratic but she
will come back and apologize own it and
accept full responsibility and not only
that but identify it and make changes
she doesn't want to be harmful I adore
that about her I think it's an admirable
quality more of us could have
um that's very different than
when you think about it there are nine
different symptoms and you only need
five to meet criteria so depending on
which symptoms you have you might be far
more calculated conniving manipulative
or you may just be more of the impulsive
kind of messy emotionally erratic type
and so there's some new research also
coming out that's even suggested that
among women
those that score higher in some of these
more calculated traits of the disorder
may actually be it may be a certain
presentation of female psychopathy
yeah are are some of these personality
disorders again probably impossible
question to answer but
how much of it is nature how much of it
is nurture or how much of it is in the
genetics and you just can't do much with
uh maybe another question a different
way to ask that is how much can you help
that how how much can you become better
that is a tough question so there's been
a ton of change in the way we've thought
about the etiology of these personality
disorders specific to borderline
personality disorder I think in general
the view is that most people believe
that it was associated with neglect or
trauma and childhood
while there is a correlation there
there's a correlation between that and
many mental health issues not just
borderline personality disorder we also
there is evidence to support a genetic
basis for this personality disorder and
there are people who have borderline
personality disorders that report no
childhood trauma or difficulty
um and I've and I have seen I you know
sometimes things just happen so
I think it's a mix I think we need to
think of it as biopsychosocial which is
generally the answer to most things when
you're talking about how a mental health
issue comes to be
I certainly think that in most cases
and here's just me speaking personally
again I think in my own work in most
cases what I see is that somebody may
have some sort of predisposition then
they go through certain life events and
learn patterns of Behaving that may
serve them well as a child in a
dysfunctional situation but end up being
very problematic later on or they just
have enough hardship that that Gene
whatever it was lying dormant that
little borderline personality disorder
Gene expresses itself and you'll see
that with things like schizophrenia
depression anxiety disorders there tend
to be certain ages where you'll just see
that expression happen